along the rivers of Britain and around her coasts
hundreds of miles of deficit harbors the Port of
London begins at present ocean-going liners and
cargo boats from all over the world come up the
Thames tonight some of them have come from the
tropics they may be carrying dangerous diseases as
soon as the ships arrive they hoist the quarantine
Bay and in response the customs launch goes out
to check the pit of hell after the pilot first
man alongside every incoming ship is the customs
officer it's an advantage to be an island it
makes it easier to keep our plates in epidemics
the ships carry on upstream to the docks
galleons reach would rather hide and poop
this ship has come from America is on her
way to Victoria Dock will unload to Bethel
Rebeca hundreds of tons of it pass through the
warehouse every month under the watchful eye
of a customs officer every cask is weighed the
rate of import duty to be paid depends amongst
other things on the moisture of the tobacco
this the customs officer finds out for himself
meanwhile the ship's captain with his agent
is on his way to the customs at
Adelaide house by London Brittany
ships captains of every nationality come
to this office to make their reports it is
called the long rope and has given its name
to other such rooms in custom houses around
the country accidents at sea drifting mind
wrecks icebergs anything of interest that's
happened during the voyage must be reported
here the most important thing the customers
want from the captain in a detailed list of the
cargo he's been carrying with the entries they
received from the importers when the captain
has made the report the papers are signed
after the tobacco has been weighed it will remain
in the warehouse for some years to mature before
it's taken away to effect it over 400 million
pounds a year comes to the Exchequer from import
duties on tobacco this is the biggest single
item of the revenue from Customs and Excise
another of our largest imports
is petrol billions of gallons
of it are handled in oil storage
depots up and down the country
the customs officer at an oil storage depo keeps
a check on the contents of each tank with a plumb
line the storage of the nation's oil supplies
is not an easy task there are very few places
where anything so inflammable can be kept with
safety yet it takes up so much room some of these
great tanks hold more than 3 million gallons even
this is less than the day's supply for the whole
country at some of the larger Depot's there is a
refinery where crude oil is made into lubricating
and diesel oils and petrol these are carried
all over the country by road rail and water
as smaller and more specialized in port
is white which produces only a few million
pounds a year for the revenue casks of
port and sherry come to London dock just
below Tower Bridge a customs officer has to
measure them that work out the exact amount
of wine in each cask this is called gauging
it's a job which requires great skill all the
casks are hand made and so they're all
slightly different in shapes and sizes
upriver from London duck is the pool overlooking
the pool is the London Custom House this was the
headquarters of the custom London custom house
this was the headquarters of the Customs and
Excise service until 1940 when it was bombed and
they moved to city gate house in Finsbury square
at City gate house the work of Customs and
Excise officials up and down the country
is coordinated any questions about the
rates of duty to the child are referred
to this office and here the policy
that guides the service is laid down
work of the Board of Customs and Excise effects
the lives of all of us over fifty million pounds
a year comes from the entertainment tax alone most
of it from the cinemas some of it will seat you're
sitting in another hundred and eighty millions
come from purchase tax almost everything we buy
with their customs duty on if it's imported
or excise duty if it's made in this country
in every distillery in Scotland an excise officer
is stationed to watch the
entire process of distilling
like the gauge at London doc he measures every
cast separately and takes a sample to
find out the amount of alcohol in the
spirits excise duty on whiskey and gin
produces over 16 million pounds a year
in the Broads as in the distiller is
an excise officer is always on duty
beer is made of a mixture of water malt
sugar and yeast before it ferments the
excise officer measures the quantity in
each VAT and test the specific gravity
every brewery is subject to excise control this
is to make sure not only that the duty is paid
but the quality of the brew is maintained
there is another side to the work of this
branch of the civil service the prevention
of smuggling all around the coasts the water
guard our statement it was they who were first
alongside the ship when she arrived now a party
of the water guard had known as a rummy have
gone on board to search for hidden contraband
the water guard know everything about ships
cargoes sailors and the ports they come from
they may pay several visits to a ship during
a single stay in harbor they search everywhere
above decks and below in the cabin holds the
engine room the ventilators and in the perks
most of the things the rummage crew finds are
trivial and the fines paid on them are only a
few pounds but if this pity smuggling will
not get done it would soon get out of hand
the rummage officer must be a bit of a detective
or after he's found the goods
it's his job to find the culprit
on aerodrums as well as in ports the
customs men are constantly on duty
of the thousands of people who travel
only a very few are professionals Magma's
the customs officers must watch for
the little signs that give them away
these jewels will be confiscated and this man will
have to pay a fine of three times their value and
so the revenue builds up a thousand million a year
one third of the annual revenue of Great Britain